hello and welcome to the video playing I
am so ma right I am yep and also great
the score and one out of three quiz that
actually gido Capri oh yeah I feel like
he won some nice game against p hit it
so earlier earlier yeah let's we'll see
what happens k
95 before is somewhat uncommon in this
position we take that okay
you
you
okay I'm going to play it simple here
playing for that d 4 square where it is
simply to take a three and route 28 or
look to it now I can actually class
along which is very very rare but why
not why not actually okay a couple of
ideas i can actually probably not i was
thinking maybe I can do something right
before word this is to a bit too
fantastic night before ever hear the
threat now strategically speaking yep so
he reacted to that I can go to d4 anyway
here and also queen to d6 attacking the
bishop and then 94 and this is actually
interesting let's do it and forced him
to capture I think Queen III or queen f2
should win some material but ok you can
play we should everyone but the move
that I don't believe in much
maybe you can play Bishop Bishop d3 i'll
take G to this is good for black if I
get the Jeep on a half night age 52 f 4
hmm Jim I also don't know really what
one should do him it's not particularly
great
Jeff I don't know a few light moves
maybe also not be 30 but it is not great
why is this a connection issue let's
check no it's okay so yeah he went for
that passive move okay I was thinking I
just double now check
I also could have taken only one so if i
do that now he has some issues with
moving or I can take I don't know what's
better provinces check it's almost the
same position i can check now on e 1 and
then look d 1 it's funny it's funny
still I'm not so super satisfied and
checking maybe night h5 is good g3 I can
take f3 yeah ok here i can check kicks
it to him
so look us Luke see one King see torquay
one hey it's got King de tu kindy to
look be one king see to shoot
this is just a drone ok then I have to
go back let's that's not good I mean
okay I still like the position here with
the better structure but it felt like I
should have more should get more
okay so look traders probably okay and
doesn't no matter which so let's see
maybe night over to d6 and then to d6
time morning
check let's see something on dark
squares probably as good I'd like to put
bishop on b3 and then denied to see for
this is what I want to do impossible
didn't work that didn't work check check
check check check didn't see the trick
check
check check check check check check
check what's this how is this connected
like four hits I'm time hmm okay weird
yeah so I know I think I always kept
something but wasn't really wasn't
really sure him yeah I don't like this
position already for white it was a
little bit yeah I think 95 this is the
only move that just make sense in
connection to the width with the capture
can something like that was what I
expected and this is interesting I
wanted to go cream back simply back my
idea is always this taking and then use
the default square gather the way it it
went I think was very nice I mean here
I'm I'm well developed and I have those
weak squares to play against and here
already a couple of good options night
h5 is also interesting yeah I wanted
wanted to make sure that I get the
bishop yeah now dark squares are really
a problem here the engine wants to do
this that even better it's not a big
difference probably check check yeah
maybe that wasn't the strongest I don't
know where the computer likes it though
yeah this is this is remarkable probably
the trade isn't so great now because I
didn't see that
I cannot use the first rank so I
probably should keep it on if he takes
this check now I'm winning here because
there is this at the end so yeah I
didn't I mean I just played this play
and now I realized okay I cannot do this
because it's a draw so back okay the
position is still slightly better for
black due to the structure but it's not
as good as our Chan hoped it would would
get this one okay I'm surprised check
that the engine things this is equal why
I said equal I mean okay while white is
probably able to draw but the position
is not equal I've got ya I got 35 okay
gets did get a-a okay okay okay i
understand her but okay but can you do
this I push him back and maybe okay
maybe it's a draw okay black and try
forever here with the better structure
anyway it is better now I keep the the
better structure yeah after that
regrouping I'm winning winning stuff
check probably not the cleanest ever
technical play but
no I could have done that chant is
simpler way but I think it always was a
winning position it didn't spoil it okay
well thanks for watching